Boeing admits for the first time that a
faulty sensor may be to blame for two
deadly crashes of its new 737 max a Jets
346 people were killed in the lion air
and Ethiopian Airlines crashes that
happened five months apart some
lawmakers want Boeing executives to
testify on what they may have known
about those faulty systems Kris Van
Cleave is at Washington's Reagan
National Airport Chris good morning good
morning a lot of questions we finally
got our hands on that preliminary report
and it paints a terrifying picture a
worst-case scenario really for the
pilots of Ethiopian Airlines flight 302
Boeing CEO who is yet to face questions
from lawmakers or reporters is now
apologizing and pledging to fix the
problems we're taking a comprehensive
disciplined approach and taking the time
to get the software update right in a
pre-recorded message Boeing CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg seems confident the 737 max
fleet will soon be ready to fly after
admitting its flight control system was
likely a major factor in two deadly
crashes it will be among the safest
airplanes ever to fly that message
followed a preliminary report by
investigators detailing the chaotic
situation that unfolded on Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 within 44 seconds of
takeoff a sensor malfunction activating
the anti stall system known as M casts
two minutes into the flight 20 seconds
later it went off again putting the
plane into a dive the pilots were able
to pull the nose up some before turning
M casts off as Boeing instructed but
were not able to regain control with
conflicting alarm sounding about 30
seconds before crashing the pilots turn
the system back on M caps fired again
putting the plane into a 40 degree
nosedive hitting a speed of 575 miles an
hour
737 captain Dennis Taser spokesman for
American Airlines pilot says Boeing must
aggressively train pilots to operate
it's updated system
this is beyond trust but verify we're in
the show-me stage and that's where this
is going to continue to be 24 year-old
Samuel Stu Moe was one of the eight
Americans among the 157 killed on flight
302 the potential of my sister and 156
others driven straight into
ground because of Boeing's greed her
family is suing Boeing and Ethiopian
Airlines they've also filed a complaint
against the FAA this is the absolute
worst pain that a human being can
experience is the death of their child
or loved one in this way and it has to
stop no more people should die
while testing the software updates for
the 737 max aimed at fixing the issues
with MCATs they have found an
integration issue with how the update
works with other systems on the plane
that's going to take a few weeks to sort
out that's before it can be sent to the
FAA for approval Anthony Chris thank you
so upsetting to read what they went
through on this plane sandy you know
it's terrifying because they knew
exactly what was happening and they knew
they were in big trouble and nothing
that they could do about it it's
terrifying to me we're gonna continue to
follow every step of the process yes yes